hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Joe beak
away so today we're gonna check out the
halo 5 Guardians the opening cinematic
trailer people have been asking me to
check this out for about a week now this
is more of a movie based channel that's
I haven't really checked it out but I
got my broseph with me today
hola see he's into video games it looks
like halo just notice today I'm nice
fireteam Osiris over the last 72 hours
five colonies have experienced identical
events massive destruction forerunner
and origin for dr. Catherine Lisbeth
Halsey has managed to contact us she
claims to have information on these
attacks palsy is currently in covenant
custody on the surface of come chata
your mission is to insert behind enemy
lines with tree palsy and bring her back
to infinity be advised dr. Halsey is
accompanied by Covenant Supreme Leader
Jewell and AMA if you have the
opportunity understood commander
good luck Spartan Locke infinity out
bracket gear online affirmative say
before we make this jump anybody want to
say a few words I figured Goggin here I
was scared I am so can everyone else is
that yes I think it is Hawking by the
first drink overdone
yeah from castle at last you buy pretty
sure the likeness is our team Osiris the
light is green
defense
think so elegant
I was cool
goodbye mom
Tommy dancer dr. mark buckle on enriched
online
what it's free yeah
please
Wow
yeah
it's also one shot
haha
christening ship cred
I had nipples chills right now yeah
so hit the Xbox one Limited Edition
Bundle mmm is more than the chief yeah
it Wars Master Chief I haven't read a
whole lot about Halo 5 um I do know that
they changed music artists in the middle
of production like they fired their
longtime composer out of nowhere and are
never really followed up on what
happened after they fired him it just
for him it just seemed like it came out
of nowhere and Microsoft was like we
love this guy we're parting ways now
we're going a different direction and
they made it seem like everything was
cool and chill but it wasn't it wasn't I
don't know why they keep making these
Halo games where they're pushing on
these other teams on the fans and I'm
like well for me I just like Master
Chief I think he's cool I tried playing
the other games that don't have Master
Chief and I just it's not the same for
me
it was almost like Metal Gear Solid 2
when you switched over to ride and I'm
like mm it's not it's not quite the same
day for me well I feel like their
marketing is kind of going in a
different direction because it off but
it always was about Master Chief you
know but then people still haven't
complained about Halo lately kind of
just being a little repetitive so I feel
like with this one they're trying to
introduce instead of a brand new
character there's like here's a whole
new set of character right so
introducing more of a co-op kind of
experience as opposed to just you know
being badass Master Chief again right
I'm looking forward to it this is one of
three games I've been looking forward to
all year long I mean I was a really cool
cinematic trailer I mean these the
[ __ ] cinematic trailers review I
pressed me more than I know but they
always look good it's like is that you
gonna do all that like yeah everything
on the game that's the sucky thing about
cinematic road is that they tend to do a
lot more than what you actually have the
option to do when your claim unless it's
uncharted yeah have you played I'm
trying to play there charted I'm gonna
play it either way I'm wonder if they're
gonna mess up mess around with the
visuals a little bit more in the actual
gameplay
maybe the perception of it because you
know I remember I think a Resident Evil
for some reason because Resident Evil
had a very specific type of game playing
the way it was shot and I think when it
came around to part 4 that's when they
changed it to a third person point of
view and you can follow the Kika film
around like the camera follows you
around instead of it being specifically
camera set up places right so I don't
know if they're going to change that up
so that way you could do more this
cool stuff but then again I'm a mess
with it maybe there could be an option
that's no people it would be a huge
backlash if it was no longer first
person I feel like you'll be okay 'they
included as an option though you know
you know you know like Grand Theft Auto
I'm trying to give you advice halo I
mean as far as cinematic trailer goes
yeah sweep and you characters don't
really hook me in any way maybe not you
but everyone who loved loved loved
Firefly is gonna be super super if
that's him it in something pretty sure
that's him the likeness is as almost as
bad as if it's not him as I thought the
Last of Us looked like what's-her-name
from Juno uh [ __ ] Ellen Page yeah I
mean they modeled it after her so
there's no way that's not a lot of games
do that now so I wouldn't be surprised
what Nathan Fillion that's his name um
like all a duty advanced warfare games
tend to do that or they they will look
like who did it look like in that game
the Kevin Spacey look-alike that was
Kevin Spacey I know and then they had
one where there was John Malkovich Jeff
Goldblum but was it those actors yeah
that's what I'm saying you don't just
officer yeah I'm green oh yeah who's
saying it wouldn't just be a look-alike
it would be that person yeah there you
go
anyway guys we're like clearly grooving
thanks for tuning into the channel if
you're do do it you can subscribe to the
real rejects you can check out the jab
eco a channel he has a lot of fun stuff
on there including reaction reviews as
well and he actually does some pretty
bomb-ass short films there's this one I
just caught been showing it off to a lot
of people lately called wave the saber
if you're into Star Wars you're gonna
like this short film trust me on that
you follow the real rejects on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine and periscope do
you have all that I have twitter at Jeb
ich away i have facebook follow javi I
have Instagram Java koi I have vine
javac away and you can just hit Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine I did wasn't
thinking
James katak greetings my name is James
kenick my channel name is also as such I
am an aspiring filmmaker and I was
wondering and I know this is a long shot
that you could react to one of my shorts
maybe I want to know if I have true
talent in this field and if so if it's
that it's worth pursuing okay my child
name is James Caddick film is raised re
ISE I review so grateful you do this for
me you have no idea how much it means
okay
James we need to talk for a second buddy
I want to know if I have true talent in
this field and if so that it's worth
pursuing
you're waiting for the approval of meet
me or the validation of one guy
validation of one guy to see if you're
worth enough to do filmmaking
first off that's a great idea it's yeah
it's genius
no go along with it it's honestly I have
the best opinions and I'll tell you
whether or not you should continue doing
this filmmaking career anything related
to this industry you don't do because
someone else tells you you're doing a
good job you do it because you love it
that's why you do it even if you [ __ ]
suck hard you keep going because you
love this profession yeah it's like Ed
Wood good example yeah it would never
give up mm-hmm he's making mortalized
even if his stuff was bad he's
immortalizing yeah he was the best that
being the worst still that's you James